bonjour Imagi bonne fête des mères
hé tu sais pas de malbouffe pour le petit
déjeuner nous permet de voir aussi te permet d'aller à l'
école sans aucun sous-vêtement son ex vient de
se remarier comme un garçon de 12 ans salut
salut me tweete tu veux vérifier ou
quoi que ce soit a fait  tu viens de me dire tweet
at-elle je pense qu'elle vient de dire tweet moi
ce dont nous avons besoin des
oeufs de jus des oeufs et des tampons bien TL sais
ce que cela signifie non ce n'est pas une
fille qui cherche ouais au même bateau deux
fils sympa de te rencontrer
Sandi avec deux fils je '  je suis sablonneux j'ai du jus
fils j'ai déjà dit que oui tu as fait des
haineux ici dans le trafic commencent à penser
à la façon dont je n'ai pas enseigné à quelqu'un je
ne me souviens même pas de notre stupide
dispute à propos d'un
quelle bonne surprise
je suis ravi de  faire de mon avenir une
femme soudaine qu'il a adoptée
s'est toujours demandé s'il venait de me jeter nous
devons trouver ta mère avez-vous des enfants la
carrière me tient occupé qui devrais-je le faire
pas
chintz viens
j'aime Imam
Oh